hallo
[Musik]
du denn hier
wie geht es dir was machst du denn hier
[Musik]
wie geht es dir hallo ich so ein zufall
dass ich dich hier treffe
so ein zufall dass ich dich hier treffe
ich wollte einen kaffee holen
weiter arbeite ich wollte einen kaffee
holen
war ich weiter arbeiten
mir geht es gut
meine firma läuft sehr gut
ich bin glücklich ich bin glücklich
so
du bist selbstständig oder
genau
ich bin meine eigene chefin
genau ich bin meine eigene chefin
das ist toll
aber auch sehr viel arbeit
ich muss oft auch an den wochenenden und
am abend arbeiten
und wie geht es dir und wie geht es dir
mir geht
lala
mir geht es so lala
[Musik]
warum was ist los
ich bin nicht mehr so zufrieden mit
meinem job
ich bin nicht mehr so zufrieden
job
wieso
die firma
altmodisch
die für
da ist ein bisschen altmodisch
meine chefs
ist komisch
meine chefin ist komisch
und meine
ex kollegen sind auch nicht sehr offen
und meine arbeitskollegen sind auch
nicht sehr offen
ich würde lieber etwas kreatives tun
[Musik]
und mit einem
den motivierten team zusammenarbeiten
und mit einem jungen motivierten team
zusammenarbeiten
ja das verstehe ich gut
es ist sehr wichtig dass man mit seinem
beruf zufrieden ist
beruf zufrieden ist absolut ich denke
dass ich bald kündigen werde
absolut ich denke dass ich bei kündigen
werde
ich habe auch
werbungen verschickt
von zwei bewerbungen verschickt
oh wie toll
dann drücke ich dir die daumen
das wird schon klappen
vital
dann drücke ich dir die daumen
[Musik]
das wird schon klappen
ja ich hoffe sehr ja ich hoffe sehr
hast du schon etwas gehört hast du schon
etwas gehört
nein leider noch nicht
nein leider noch nicht aber es werden
sich wohl viele für die stelle bewerben
aber es werden sich wohl viele für die
stelle bewerben
klar aber es ist wichtig dass du an dich
glaubst
ich denke dass du gute chancen hast
du bist ja sehr kompetent
und sympathisch du bist ja sehr
kompetent
und sympathisch vielen dank das ist lieb
von dir
vielen dank das ist lieb von dir
ich muss zurück zur arbeit
weiterhin alles gute
vielen dank ich wünsche dir einen
schönen tag
das wünsche ich dir auch das wünsche ich
dir auch bis bald
hallo na na wie geht es dir
hallo ich bin ein bisschen müde aber es
geht mir prima und dir
ich bin ein bisschen müde aber es geht
mir prima und dir
mir auch
ich habe gute neuigkeiten
ich habe gute neue
reiten
wirklich erzählt wirklich erzähl ich
habe dir doch erzählt dass ich mich um
eine stelle bei einer tollen firma
beworben habe
ich habe dir doch erzählt dass ich mich
um eine stelle bei einer tollen firma
beworben habe
ja genau und
sie haben mich zu einem
bewerbungsgespräch eingeladen
sie haben mich zu einer
gespräch eingeladen
ich darf mich nächste woche bei der
firma vorstellen
so cool gratuliere
das freut mich sehr so cool
gratuliere
das freut mich sehr ja mich auch
aber ich bin ein bisschen nervös
ja mich auch
aber ich bin ein
nervös
das musst du nicht sein
sei einfach du selbst
dann klappt das schon
das musst du nicht sein
sei einfach du selbst
dann klappt das schon
vielen dank du ich muss los
ich muss mit den hunden spazieren
kein problem
ich wünsche dir einen
den abend
kein problem
ich wünsche dir einen schock
den abend
das wünsche ich dir auch
und toi toi toi beim bewerbungsgespräch
wann ist es ist am dienstag um 16 uhr
wann ist es
es ist am dienstag um 16 uhr
alles klar ich denke an dich
auf wiedersehen
abonniere die halo deutsch schule auch
auf instagram oder facebook abonniere
die halo deutsche schule auch auf
instagram oder facebook möchtest du
gratis online deutsch lernen mehr als
200 video lektionen abonniere unseren
kanal möchtest du gratis online deutsch
lernen mehr als 200 video lektionen
abonniere unseren kanal